[موسيقى]
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
حيوانات حيوانات
بيت وفي الغابات تعطي جمالا للحياه يا
لجمال كان تعطي جمالا للحياه يا جمال
الكائنات
[موسيقى]
بصياحي دوما صدى اوقظكم في كل صباح بسياح
دوما
اوقظكم في كل صباح له هيبه بين الطيور انا
الديك المحبوب يس
الطيور انا الديك المحبوب
[موسيقى]
البشر انا اغلى صديق لي صوت ويسمى نهير
للبشر انا اغلى صديق لصوت ويسمى نهير
مشهور ادعى الحمار للجهد وللتعب يطير
مشهور ادعو الحمار للجهد ولل
هنا وهناك انط والعب طول النهار انا لا
اتعب هنا وهناك انط والعب طول النهار انا
لا اتعب انظروا ما احلى اذني محبوب واسمى
الارنب انظروا ما احلى اذني محبوب واسمى
الارنب
[موسيقى]
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لجمال الكائنات تعطي
جمالا للحياه يا جمال الكائ
نات
انا المعزه قد جئت الان تميزني عده الوان
فقوام رشيق وقوي واعطيكم اشهى الالباب
فقوام رشيق وقوي واعطيكم اشهى الالبان
وانا سفينه الصحراء هناك تعيش بدون عناء
جمل ويميزني سلام وايضا بالصبر عن الماء
جمل ويميز لسلام وايضا بالصبر عن
الماء
[موسيقى]
منقار اعرض اطول طيبه القلب انا الاجمل لي
منقار اعرض اطول طيبه القلب انا الاجمل
انا اسبح في البركه وبها اقضي وقتا افضل
انا بطه اسبح في البركه وبها اقضي وقتا
افضل
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لجمال الكائنات تعطي
جمالا للحياه يا جمال الكائ
[موسيقى]
نات